hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I've
got new names to put on the locker here
and some of them are good ideas some of
them are bad ideas starting off with
bulla brief said actually mark there's a
rumor that you can tame a Reaper
Leviathan just imagine it swimming
around with one of those terrifying
things on your side I don't think that's
true I don't care how many papers I feed
it is don't think that's true
awesome Adam Wolff who said there's
supposed to be a pet you can get called
the cuttlefish it says their eggs are
located in the Lost River laboratory
deep grand reef de Ghazi sea bass dunes
and the sinkhole mushroom forest I will
eventually go find that I don't know if
I'll be able to do that this episode
because I kind of want to get the
hatching enzymes and get that out of
there and then I want to get started on
the other thing but I will get to that
eventually
and then finally Jack sin of sloth who
said if you travel to the dead zone the
edge of the map is subnautica you will
find the adult ghost Leviathan and
probably your all to untimely demise
just a heads up if you manage to travel
8,000 meters down you'll be teleported
back to life pod 5 well thank you very
much for that and I don't like the
implication that there is an adult ghost
Leviathan because I've already
encountered the ghost Leviathan
illegitimately I suppose but I
encountered the ghost Leviathan I don't
want to encounter an adult ghost
Leviathan but that's exactly what I'm
gonna do so everybody everybody buckle
up it's it's gonna be a bumpy ride
I'm gonna take some people's with me
just in case
ok so here's the thing I'm gonna go
Cheerilee by the skinny skin on my my
skinny skin I'm gonna go and I'm just
gonna swim
I'm just gonna swim all the way until I
reach the quote-unquote dead zone now
I'm pretty much in the center of the
maps it's gonna take a bit but everybody
just hold on hold on to your hats I just
pissed myself
Zama go to the edge of the map let's see
how true this is and I don't know if a
peepers gonna help well I got one
alright here we go
oh man I'm far out
oh man I'm far oh man okay I'm very far
I ship hot boomerang what do you do
we're doing out here whoo oh there's a
paper there's another paper
okay well at least I know I got papers
out here oh I hate this I hate this I
hate this is not night oh god I have a
paper for you I am go my god oh my god
[Music]
holy [ __ ] oh those terrifying Oh
oh my god
okay well there I alright well got some
fresh piss out of that that's that's
some nice
what's the let's see uh ecological dead
zone all about here we go creators edge
the geological scans of this area showed
steep decline in all directions this
data is consistent with the theory that
the Aurora crashed on the edge of two
kilometer by two kilometer volcanic
crater it has likely been millennia
since an eruption reached the surface
encouraging the ecosystem within the
crater to flourish
the ecology of the trance rounded the
crater supports only two kinds of life
microscopic glass alrighty then
exploration is ill-advised wow that's
convenient
ah alright ok anyway glad we did that
I'm really glad I'm really really glad
now that that's all said and done and we
have we have finished being stupid now
we can get on with the rest of the thing
that we need now what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna go for the hatching enzyme
samples right now I'm gonna take bubble
gum on a maiden voyage here and we're
gonna go find these places now we can't
go too deep which means that I don't
think that we can get all of these until
we upgrade the the the diving module to
like MK 3 at least or MK 2 at least but
we're gonna do what we can ok I just
gave I pissed myself but I just gave
bubble gum here a storage module so that
I can have a little extra storage on my
way now the first place we're gonna go
to is the ball zone which has two of the
ingredients that we need for the the
hatching enzymes Karen I missed you I
missed you baby and I know that you
greeted me before in this particular
seamoth but
you know I was a little aggressive dude
because I was still mourning the loss
now I've completely forgotten about the
seamoth and I'm all about bubblegum as
are we all
hey can I get a stock or tooth from you
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna need an amble
glass hey bite my ass bite it bite my
ass bite my ass bite my ass hey what are
you doing bite my ass wait wait dude
dude come on I'm inviting you I'm
inviting you to bite my ass all right
that didn't work but then again that
never works and I don't know why but it
never ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever works when I want it to work so
we're gonna carry on as if nothing
happened and we're gonna get these
goddamn samples one of these is very
easy like this tonight I see I could get
three of them actually because I think
one of them is just this this mushroom
sample I'm pretty sure you just need a
piece of this bad boy and if I get a
piece of disre where'd you go whoa
bubble gum bubble gum you watch you you
watch yourself around here I ain't gonna
let a Reaper get you again not that it
got you before I'm kind of projecting my
old failures upon myself right now
and applying them to you but that
doesn't matter who's there better not be
anybody important the second thing is
one of these bad boys right here this is
all I need so okay I think that's it all
right hey hey hey boobies happy you nose
happy me I hang on oh why am i out why
okay all right we're fine okay so the
other thing is a very rare one and I
believe it's in this zone but it's just
very rare it's the C crown I found it
before beau
okay great it's the sea crown they need
to find it again that's not it it's
their way ow my ass can you not smack
the goddamn Reaper Leviathan decides to
be a sneaky peeking get me out of
nowhere I'm gonna be how did that how
did that hurt me
son of a tip oh that's awfully it could
splode ii around here it's just a
heart-pounding thing being like why is
it like perpetual darkness over here - I
can't it be some sort of lightness you
know happy fun times down under the sea
under the sea why's everything gotta be
terrible all the time oh my god oh my
god Oh
whoo-hee this myself hey hey hey whoa
whoa whoa wait hang on a second I think
that I'll that's that's it isn't it god
damn it oh well of course it is okay
oh that was hard to find all right okay
it was impossible I couldn't have seen
that from a distance how is that even
fair
okay whatever is fine I'm almost dead
that was absurdly difficult I don't know
I took so long I gotta get back to my
bait all right die but at least I got it
so I got our got like three no I got too
many of those I've got three of the food
okay all right I'm out I'm out I get it
I'm not welcome here I get it I get it I
get it I get it
all right I'm now welcome here but I got
three of the five which is good and
there's only two left and then I can
make hatching enzymes and then I'm good
to go I'm good to go
ah hate hate to just hate all right
anyway so the other two are exactly
shave before I mysteriously died in a
horrible way that was an ordeal already
but the other one the iStock I believe
it's in the I believe it's in the
underwater caves but I'm not 100% sure
about that I mean I'll fight it find out
soon enough but not terribly worried
about it that ordeal thankfully is a
little bit over not a hundred percent
over but just a little bit over I'm
gonna dock this real quick and big box
berry here long PD wonky okay yeah
thanks Kevin
all right whatever your name is I don't
even remember let's get some potatoes
oh god I've got too many secrets do I
even need these do I have indeed these
for anything because I could grow more
if I really wanted to do but I don't
really I'm gonna put you in the
punishment one boat oh okay I'm good
yeah that was an ordeal I don't know why
that one's always an ordeal but it was
an ordeal all right well these are oh no
these are good gonna gimme gimme
okay ah me one replant the other
easy-peasy
[Music]
Boop and okay my potatoes growing don't
want these to wash down I'm good to go
all right I'm good to go huh it's sorry
I'm just a little stressed okay so I've
got those you are so close so close
you're a big one oh you're a big one
okay so oh all right
let me think about what I need to do so
I gotta find well I'm gonna find one
more of these bad boys I'm gonna find
one more of these bad boys I'm gonna
find one more of these bad boys
and then I'm gonna try to get one from
the let's see if I can close out like
let's see if I can get all five I'm
pretty sure I can it's just not 100%
sure if I can by I'm pretty sure I can
only go on the adventure
Fushimi repair me first okay don't drift
away from me that's gone now that we're
a little less dead I'd be lovely so I
need to go to a kelp cave to get the ice
talk and then the blood kelp I can
probably swim down on my own alone which
I don't want to do but I can do it what
the hell Oh some black mossy fish so
pancha swim bladders oh he don't look so
good all right but I'm gonna go get
these if I don't get them then that's
fine if I do get them then I'm dead
weight no backwards that's not the way
uh-huh
ah now that is a blood kelp zone and I
don't want to go I don't want to go down
there by hand but I think that's the
only thing that I can do at the moment
and I'm pretty sure the ghost weed is
gonna be down there so time to stop
being a wait is it up here maybe there's
a ghost weed up here and I don't have to
go down there don't look like it I guess
I'm going down whoo-hoo-hoo yes that is
you I don't have to go down by myself
yes yes yes II
yes your baby all right sorry
there we go I don't know I had to do
that sound but you know it is what it is
I do need these four for polyaniline so
I'm gonna get as many deep shrooms as I
can stuff my pockets full of shroom all
right I'm Audi I just need one more
which is a nice stock and I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure that gotta be from
like the deep caves and not these things
so I've got shoes and I've got
everything and then I've got extra
storage and bubble gum before anything
else that I could possibly need but I'm
doing good I can get the last one yeah
I'm an accomplished person on the oven
accomplished human being that does tasks
and executes them I have plans and then
I do plans yeah haha okay I'm getting
near where am I actually let me get a
bearing I
it also says it's in the crag fields
which I believe yeah they're just on the
ass end of the aurora maybe near Reaper
territory I don't know but I'm getting
close to it so if it's in the Krag field
then it should be a lot easier to find
than in some anonymous cave in the kelp
zone but I'm just gonna keep my peepers
peeled well that looks craggy is this
the crag field yeah this is it you okay
yeah all right oh okay yeah I believe
you
okay crag field all right let's see if
you've got some eye stocks because
that's what I need right now
that's a thorny bush where's the highest
stalk
thorny bushes oh there we go
don't hit me thorny bouche I got you no
no no no no no I will not be swayed I
will not be swayed I will not be swayed
you hypnotic bastard okay I got all of
them yeah oh let's see if I can get back
home safe without running in anything
devious ah home sweet home okay all
right okay
not so bad not so bad at all this is
going rather well all right I got my
hunt for the materials that I noted now
I just gotta settle my score with the
Emperor and I don't know why I said it
so ominously but I got everything I need
and that should allow me to do what I
need to do I have everything in bubble
butt over there I'll plug transfer it
over to big box Barry to actually make
the trip because I'm pretty sure that
the depth required and the sea emperor's
cave is not good enough for little ol
bubble gum over there plus I want to
protect bubble gum and I don't want
bubble gum to die so thank you everybody
so much for watching in the next episode
I will cure myself and get started on
building the rocket pad so that we can
get off of this rock once and for all
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know your thoughts down
in the comments below now bit my lip and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]